what is in your pack we're getting in
the back we're getting all the back
things bags and more bags I only carry a
backpack to work like generally I don't
have a bank reg I don't carry it unless
I'm at work I never used to carry around
a bag I always just had my wallet with
me but then my mom sent me this bag I
was just like a gift and I was like okay
I'll just use it I've been told it's a
mob bag and what can't wait to see it
did you clean your bag before I left
stuff in there but I took out most of
the trash
no I don't see I have a lot of stuff
we're gonna fight yeah okay so this is
oh okay yeah no this is a mom bag I see
it pretty cute like a chic mom it's cute
right yeah this mom like she I use it
enough that it's now falling apart all
right I've got a clip on the bag in case
I ever need it really I don't think I've
ever used it since I put it on there
this is a lucky cabbage oh this is
handmade I don't know about him made
probably but my boyfriend's cousin gave
it to me that's precious cute are they a
child a little brown adult my boyfriend
he gave me this it says the best drama
queen honestly this you this is the best
thing I love this okay then we've got
gum we've got the order oh is that me
it is why I am innocent I don't know I
like I like the smell of that one this
is my wallet so this is what you used to
carry I just yeah I just used to carry
this bad boy around this is my big old
bag of tampons why why I mean I guess is
better to have them in a bag because
I've seen people have just like loose
tampons in them so here's the thing yeah
it was bought in a box form I was
traveling at the time I didn't want to
carry it in a box because bucks
SOT like his love space takes up a lot
of space so I put it in there it's gonna
flatten out that's so many dupont's all
I ask for that many tampons I've never
had a period so I don't know I mean I
only used about like four of them anyway
this is setting powder
moisturizer I like to stay dewy a nice
glow yes I just had sex glow no my cell
phone you keep it in your bag on our
your pockets sometimes it's in my bag
sometimes my pockets kind of depends
hmm okay like it got a I shot a pallet
lots of makeup it seems I mean you know
me dad's back I lose $5 bills Mart I
like this
try shampoo headphones because my phone
doesn't really work without headphones
if I'm on FaceTime or something that's
very there's a lot of Rosling in the
bottom of this bag now now we're getting
down to the nitty-gritty like the big
things tinted moisturizer my keys you
put anything in your pockets not really
eyeliner lip liner lip gloss concealer
more lip gloss Wow
so your honor that's not out of the
package yet I've heard that if you stay
ready you don't got to get ready
exactly highlight more lip liner how
frequently do you remain cup brush
reapply your makeup not that often but
as you said just in case they ready
don't gotta get ready
that's a little eye cream can I get to
work early I have in haven't put it on
for the day get to work early I'm like
we're a little crusty under the eyes
let's just pop on some eye cream
sunglasses I know I shouldn't put these
in my bag
so they're gonna get destroyed I have
already had to superglue one of the nose
things on so this what even is that this
is a portable charger it looks like a
floppy disk is that the point that's
what it's like oh so this is like
supposed to be funny I thought this
allusion to me was for your computer I'm
like what do you have what works really
well actually I hold the long-term self
and anyway we've got a band-aid okay
again got a ticket to the no Akali Brown
House Museum in Denver Colorado can we
pause on this band-aid why is it crusty
like it is like they just like stains on
it is it pre huge no I just think it's
an old band-aid that's just from like
the 80s what that weathered I guess I'm
not using that band-aid um and a loose
tampon
yes smart cuz you know you thought you
thought that would happen
oh there's a there's a nail in there
there's a broken nail in there broken
little toss it on my back
ah heat up that same color cherish this
forever gross and then I've got some
coins some candies that are stuck to the
bottom of whether you like the grandma
candy they're my favorite these are my
pens someone at work keeps stealing my
felt-tip pens and now they stay with me
all the time because if they stay with
me no one's stealing them bear well you
thought that was all it's not this it's
a card game that was once a board game
now is a card game listen to a card yeah
they did I don't know anyway I keep it
with me all the time in case I want to
teach someone how to play it because I'm
obsessed of it I've got to face masks
these are hydrating college and iPads
where would you ever need these going
out like these are all things you use in
your home again I travel with this bag
Oh another loose tampon I couldn't find
this chapstick and now I know Passport
oh there's a safety strap for this this
might sound really morbid but my dog's
died like year ago and that is both
really precious and kind of scary all of
them with me all the time he was like my
baby you think a lot into your bag
there's not realizing that now not in a
bad way I feel like it is like you like
you said in true mom form you are like
characters and I like that
prepped prepped and you even have a
crusty bandage really really don't
they'd be okay with using it well your
bag was very eventful I feel like mine
is going to disappoint it's uh it's my
backpack I love this bag I get
compliments on it everywhere I go
thank you so let's just dive right into
this thing I'm gonna lay it down
he sounds heavy oh yeah she's hurting my
laptop's in here so I keep my laptop
case in here with my laptop well this is
just my work computer fuzzy I there's a
felt theme a wooden case people also
think this is a
bored all the time I'm reading Harry
Potter for the first time so I travel
with I'm on the six books yeah I didn't
read them as a kid because I didn't say
I got through the most kids this is a
script I'm me and a friend are working
on a short so this is a page from a
script and then quizzes from another
video I've done
I bet might usually just ends up being a
catch-all for like items things that
does yeah
headphones as well no just wireless
headphones I keep the make world
yeah because the other ones and it got
lost I literally don't know so now I
keep them in my bag we're actually
friends I knew that he loves them yeah
no this is yeah legitimate looking
sunglasses as well same problem no I
will you pull him out I was like
honestly I have like the exact same
sunglasses spin sand ride on this scene
it's Benson ride reporting for duty
being in in it better
Benson rice on Miami kind of I have a
computer charger which for my laptop so
that stays in my bag this is a to-do
list I've done none of the things on
this to-do list and this is from days
ago could help I told my digital
reminders I keep a portable fan because
I get hot I have a pretty sweaty guy
sometimes so I keep a little in it and
if she works she's a powerful little man
this is like it comes in handy
yeah so if you do this pop that in let
me do this you keep going okay I keep
this really nice pin I think I got it
yeah moment yeah I got it as a
graduation gift from like my advisor in
grad school SD card holders like I have
a bunch of SD cards and then there's
just like emergency the smooshed
emergency I was getting over a cold and
so I had that and then like a buttload
of cough drops
my bed and that's really all I because I
keep thinking about pockets a lot like
my keys in my pocket my ID my wallet my
phone like most things go in my pockets
I'm surprised as you carry your passport
to me that just seems like a very
dangerous lot with the bag I just keep
it in international my bag is always
with me yeah well no but I'd rather
carry this with me in an airplane then
like have to go through my wallet and
pull out my thing this is just in the
pocket
I guess because your wallet is in your
bag so it's more of a price yes I can
just like yeah okay clutch with the
deodorant I probably just aren't
carrying me over anymore
all these things only a few of them I
like intentionally put in my bag a lot
of them just like up here appeared along
the way I kind of thought that I would
have more stuff in my bag than you so
I'm not necessarily surprised by that
yeah mine is more like a combination of
things prepared for most anything yes do
you want a face mask you get a face that
that's smart all I can do is give you
some emergency income but you know
that's another case of Ryan Spence
[Music]
that's so bad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]